veloci veloci 5 pezzo di merda 321
spende bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo nuovo video sono favi geri ed
oggi siamo sud art direction dark days
action può va bene basta allo ragazzi
prima di cominciare volevo dirvi che è
praticamente si tratta del videogame
horror che simula una specie di pacman
solo in versione non tanto da bambini
diciamo va bene anche se questo
ragazzino dopo farci almeno una volta
farlo perché è fantastico dal rischio le
semi plex che ci sono tranquilla siders
blerim spaceflight africa e non sto
comportando un cazzo di quello che dice
però quello è un figo della madonna al
premio west nile affanculo
abbiamo iniziato lega allora ragazzi
dovrà accogliere sticozzi praticamente
lo stoppa e questo ovviamente se
conoscete pac man
in poche parole conoscete pure questo
perché non è che cambiano tanto le
regole solo che non capire dove devo
andare a vado di quarta o kay fin qua ci
siamo siamo tornati a punto già miste
impappinandosi amo appena iniziato
buongiorno ragazzo ok allora vediamo di
karin albou siamo partiti da un minuto
di merda da un [ __ ] minuto quindi ovi
calmate ovi calmate quando ci sono
ancora andato bene non a caso a caso a
capri
a caso una sega ho fatto cagare come
prima partita ma non gli importa voi non
avete visto niente più sexy che sei sì
però non devo guardare i quadri sono
muoio subito allora devo raccoglierli
tutti in poche parole senza farmi
peccato che quando io li sento
avvicinarsi ma non so dove sono sti
rifacciamo un attimo [ __ ] tutto
rifarli faccio perché è partita da sud
da cani ok adesso ci siamo abbiamo tutta
la vita e [ __ ] tutto adesso vinco
senza morire ma anche una volta mia me
ne sbatto di tutto eccolo rossi c'è
rossi già tensioni in curva a rossi
incredibile ancora lui ancora luca vaga
la canonica caffè io mi perdo mi perdo
inglese cosi pulito pezzo di stronzo che
ci ho già provato però e questo glielo
devo concedere allora devo capire un
attimo come si possono uccidere si cose
tipo in panchina mangiavi quel costo di
abeti permetterà di mangiare i fantasmi
ma non segua funzione effettivamente
lirica calmi che non sto capendo dove
sono i nemici e la cosa inquietantissimo
devo ho capito dove sono ho capito dove
sono o che col petto capito bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye eccolo eccolo ancora tutto il
ragazzo sto facendo sto facendo non so
come me lo sto facendo vai vai
ho trovato qualcosa non chiedetemi cosa
ma va bene devo capire ancora dove sto
andando perché visto continuando a
girare a caso nel tentativo di vincere
il macchia ma qualcosa mi dice che non
ce la faccio non fa niente regali ci
provo quale devo si maggio state le
lampadine mio zio carminati che già non
vedo una marca 81 chi è perfetto come
non detto le gabbie regalano capito se
c'è un modo per capire come spuntano se
va a culo perché io sto andando sto
andando a culo nel caso non l'avesse
capito calmi sì sì no no merda ok no
frequanti cazzo siete allora fermi
tramite anni via di coppia di pavia dico
ok ok lo dribla quanti ne marchio
allargando tordo c'è più cazzo questa
non ho preso a questi ok perfetto
ok ne mancano due ne mancano due ne
mancano 2 mar da che palle ok 111 sono
uno no no a [ __ ]
ok l'incarico ricoperto di qua una sega
ragazzi morti di prova senza neanche
morino una volta giù la voglio far ci
pensa nemmeno tagli e niente da adesso
se la faccio a prescindere non ne frega
niente
ok vai vai vai così vai così vai così
dove siete come regalo mi sto già
perdente ok dai che già si fa dai che ce
la si fa e tragico so se ci fosse lo
slang sarebbe più tragico ma non c'è lo
slang quindi va bene così
e sto andando completamente a caso lo
soltanto farvi notare che quella merda
di scimmie continuano a spuntare in
avanti senza che io dica niente credo
che vada culo perché non
non lo so questo presentimento chiaro ma
si sta roba bonus più 10 sardi che ho
preso p10 cristalli ok ultimi
venticinque me ne mancano solo
praticamente ho vinto se non ha vinto
una serie non dovevo dirlo però poiché
vara calmi calmi calmi che non vedo un
cazzo calmi ok via via veloci veloci
veloci 5 pezzo di merda cioè non si può
fare cosa sider stai zitta [ __ ]
allora calmi ho iniziato da un [ __ ]
secondo e tu già che mi many le palle
allora vediamoli calmarci tutta la tua
sorella ma non è possibile che non si
può fare un [ __ ] m per oh mio dio
vediamo di ical macinati così non ho
capito cosa serve lo zoom sembra che
faccia così con la testa ma non ho
capito il senso ma avanti avanti avanti
avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti ok ok
madonna ma che spesso è poi questo che
tipo sto prendendo due miliardi di
prezzi di pezzi di pezzi di stronzo come
te a te adesso veramente basta l'ho già
detto 20 volte basta ma adesso adesso
seriamente basta me ne frega niente ora
si finisce e non me ne frega una mazza
non dico basta perché non c'è più c'è
più verso di perdere ok dal mit no no no
no non regala impossibile sto gioco però
ma siete ovunque
siete ovunque 43 è fattibile regali e
fattibile cosa cosa strana è non ci
posso credere
ok ok ok me 28 28
perché spiega calmi calmi ragazzi ce la
possiamo fare
la possiamo fare se 18 ragazzi si sono
gli altri di qua sì sì sì no no no no no
no
credo che comunque abbiano le mie
istruzioni per casey mi è così io non le
ho mai viste in vita mia allora allora
allora allora mancano 143 dai che si può
fare dai che si può far dai che si può
fare non si può fare una sega per in
qualche modo dovrei riuscirci dal 100 di
197 più 10 90 se sento quelle che mi
stanno alle calcagna tipo che mi stanno
mordendole orecchie ma non mi giro da
merda dai che ce la posso fare manca
pochissimo
allora di qua i comici non ci sono
andato perfetto si cui sono stato qui
senza tanto 665 non fatto quattro regate
4 3 2 1 1
dov'è no no no no mi incazzo è mica
giuro che mi cazzo giuro che mi incazzo
l'ho preso ho vinto casco è impossibile
sucate stanze di scimmie poche volute
che fate anche abbastanza schifo che ti
ho fatto un minuto 54 secondi il record
mondiale legato con ansia addosso che
non avete idea reca un secondo perché lo
so che era un po corto ragazzi scusate
vi si è durato così poco però volevo
assolutamente farlo perché meritava un
casino volevo farlo perché come gioco
assolutamente epico per che minchia
meglio di così non potevamo farlo un
ragazzino direi che possono includere
qui spero che video vi sia piaciuto
comunque servito a progettare stato un
commento mi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione se non se ne per i
siti iscrivetevi non ci vediamo al
prossimo video sono le scimmie rega con
le scimmie che mi fanno incazzare quindi
succedono ste cose
è normale se lo stand e prestiti
iscrivetevi si vedranno prossimo video
due ragazzi